[Applaus]
[Musik]
emanuele makro scheint der perfekte
politiker zu sein ja alle anspricht er
ist gerade doch progressiv genug um
hollywood schauspieler zu bezaubern und
hinreichend wirtschaftsliberal streamen
dazu verführen außerhalb frankreichs
will einfach jeder 111 makro haben bei
den franzosen selbst hingegen ist das
schon eine ganz andere geschichte
aufgepasst brände brechen in paris aus
der generalstreik verursacht einen
verkehrstag traum und schließt den
eiffelturm und u-bahn-station diese
nachricht stammt aus ihnen wochen bevor
die korona pandemie in den medien
ausbrach im grunde müssten uns diese
geschichten aber nicht sonderlich
überraschen derartige ausschreitungen
sind in frankreich so üblich wie kosmos
und mensch hat trotzdem lohnt es sich
diesmal genauer hinzusehen und zu
hinterfragen warum die franzosen dieses
mal protestieren nun diesmal geht es um
nichts geringeres als die rentenreform
[Musik]
heute wollen wir uns aber gar nicht mit
den details demografischer
horrorszenarien des kontinents
beschäftigen sondern uns gezielt ein
eklatantes beispiel herauspicken
vielleicht fragst du dich warum wir
diesbezüglich gerade frankreich gewählt
haben was ist doch so besonders nun
sagen wir es in aller deutlichkeit die
schwächsten glieder werden die ganze
kette als erstes zum reißen bringen und
frankreich treibt es neben spanien
italien eben ganz besonders dort also
die länder haben ein umlagesystem bei
denen die heutigen arbeitnehmer direkten
der heutigen rentner bezahlen obwohl sie
sich in einem unglaublichen irrglauben
befinden
sie würden irgendwie ihre eigene
altersrente zusammen sparen
pustekuchen immer weniger junge menschen
zahlen ein und immer mehr alte menschen
wollen ihre rente
das system steht am rande des kollaps
wenn deutschland vor dem abgrund steht
betrag reiche schon einen schritt weiter
sein der zusammenbruch der rentensysteme
ist dort nicht nur irgendein problem er
ist ein unglaubliches himmelschreiendes
desaster aber nun weniger politiker
wollen ernsthaft darüber reden denn alle
lösungen würden extrem unpopuläre
maßnahmen nach sich ziehen
sozusagen extrem unschöne bilder jeder
politiker weiß nämlich dass derjenige
der den bürgern als erster die blanke
wahrheit ins gesicht sagt dass es
nämlich einfach kein geld mehr für die
renten gibt als erster gelöscht wird
damit du dir eine vorstellung machen
kannst frankreich hat das großzügigste
rentensystem der welt französischer
erhalten im schnitt 61 prozent ihres
letzten gehalts wären sie in deutschland
nur 38 prozent erhalten der oecd
durchschnitt liegt bei 49 prozent
dazu kommt dass das französische
renteneintrittsalter für den erhalt ein
land ohne abzüge bei 62 jahren liegt zum
vergleich in spanien liegt es bei 65
jahren was bald auf 67 jahre angehoben
wird
die im schnitt hat übrigens sogar die
vorherige sozialistische regierung
geschlossen der in deutschland liegt das
renteneintrittsalter übrigens heute
schon weil 67 und ich weiß dass viele
von euch jetzt denken also diese makro
er will die renten sinken und das
rentenalter erhöhen nicht war nun nichts
dergleichen malkurs rentenreform geht
gar nicht so weit sie betrifft weder das
eintrittsalter noch die rentenhöhe
die frage lautet also was für ein
problem haben die franzosen was passt
ihnen jetzt wieder nicht einmal groß
rentenreformen und noch wichtiger wird
mal kreisreform überhaupt irgendwie zur
lösung des europäischen renten problems
beitragen potter bände all diese fragen
beantworten
aber ihr wisst schon wir müssen dazu
einen kurzen blick auf die geschichte
werfen
[Musik]
überreste des sonnenkönigs
in den letzten 100 jahren hat sich
frankreichs sonnenkönig von der
absolutistischen monarchie zu einer der
stärksten demokratien der welt
entwickelt es gibt jedoch etwas das
nicht oft erwähnt wird der
absolutistische könig frankreichs war
nicht die einzige person privilegien
hinter ihm stand ein ganzer hofstaat aus
adligen beamten bediensteten die alle
ebenfalls viel besser legten als das
einfache volk und dann kam die
französischen revolution
das wort ergriff macht unter dem banner
der freiheit gleichheit und
brüderlichkeit
und hier kommt jeder teil der ist nicht
in die geschichtsbücher geschafft hat ja
es stimmt die revolutionäre haben dem
könig den kopf abgeschlagen und auch
vielen anderen aber du kannst kein neues
land aufbauen indem du einfach alle
eliten tötest die es vorher regiert
haben die revolution kam also und ging
wieder
aber die eliten bliebe
bevölkerungsgruppen die es schafften
ihre privilegien zu behalten und das
nicht nur für ein paar jahre
ich spreche von privilegien die bis zum
heutigen tage andauern da gibt es zum
beispiel das cordevalle und die
mitarbeiter der pariser oper ihr seid
1698 ein besonderes rentenrecht genießen
er du hast richtig gehört 1698 das ist
der grund warum wir im zwanzigsten
jahrhundert nachrichten die diese lesen
können die pariser oper in streik zur
verteidigung der rentenformel wie
kartons ludwig games vierzehnten welches
privileg gewertete sonnenkönig also den
tänzern nun nichts geringeres als das
recht mit 42 jahren in den ruhestand zu
gehen
ja ich weiß dass tanzen eine sehr
anspruchsvolle kunst ist und den
menschlichen körper bis zum äußersten
treibt okay aber es gibt drei dinge die
ich dir sagen möchte erstens kann ich
als tanzlehrer dir versichern dass
tanzen unglaublich gesund ist für körper
und geist und tänzer in der regel viel
gesünder sind als alle anderen im traum
will ich nicht daran denken mit 42 in
rente zu gehen
zweitens kann man nicht abstreiten dass
sowohl medizin als auch andere
lebensumstände sogar in frankreich in
den vergangenen drei jahrhunderten ein
wenig fortgeschritten sind und so einer
erheblichen verlängerung der
lebenserwartung geführt haben
und drittens ist ist ein skandal dass
die mitarbeiter der puppen mit seiner
motto keine solche spezielle regelung
haben denn dieses vorgelegt kommt nur
allen nachfolgern jeder tänzer so gute
die vor 400 jahren den sonnenkönig
unterhielten also denjenigen die an der
riesa überarbeiten mit anderen worten es
hätte sich um ein durch und durch
ungerechtes privileg wie aus dem
lehrbuch klar die pariser oper ist jetzt
kein riesiger arbeitgeber mag so
einwänden start geht ist zwar ungerecht
wird aber das ganze system nicht zum
abschluss bringen natürlich damit hast
du recht aber warte ein moment denn
dieses privileg ist ganz und gar kein
einzelfall
[Applaus]
du wirst also einen riesigen arbeitgeber
bitteschön die staatliche französische
eisenbahngesellschaft sncf betreibt den
französischen eisenbahnsektor im rahmen
eines monopols und alle ihre mitarbeiter
gelten als die privilegierten in
frankreich sie können mit zwei dritteln
ihres gehalts im jugendlichen alter 150
jahren in den ruhestand gehen
im rahmen einer sonderregelung die aus
jener zeit stammt als lokführer noch
kohle schaufeln mussten obwohl jeder
renteneintrittsalter im jahr 2024 auf 52
jahre steigen wird werden die sncf
beschäftigten weiterhin ein jahrzehnt
weniger arbeiten müssen als andere
französische arbeitnehmer so und jetzt
halte ich fest in frankreich gibt es
sage und schreibe 42 dieser sonder
rentensysteme wie du siehst liegt die
gewährung von privilegien in der
französischen den es ganz gleich ob das
system demokratie absolute monarchie
oder kaisertum reist und natürlich
ließen sie sich auch nicht die
gelegenheit entgehen viele neue
privilegien einzuführen als mitte des
zwanzigsten jahrhunderts der sozialstaat
gegründet wurde die der visuellen
politik erwarten das problem ist nicht
der wohlfahrtsstaat an sich sondern
seine ausprägung ob es sich eher um ein
elitäres oder ein egalitäre sozialsystem
handelt
[Musik]
zum beispiel ist der wohlfahrtsstaat in
nordischen ländern wie schweden sehr
großzügig gegenüber jedem bedürftigen
bürgern allerdings haben dort beamte
keine besonderen privilegien wie es in
anderen europäischen ländern wie
deutschland oder eben in extremer form
in frankreich der fall ist in
skandinavien werden staatsdiener als
mittelschicht betrachtet und es wird als
nicht angemessen angesehen dass sie
irgendwelche besonderen privilegien
genießen sollten all das macht sinn wenn
wir bedenken wer die vertreter des
schwedischen wohlfahrtsstaat waren die
schwedischen sozialdemokraten kam aus
der arbeiterklasse
deshalb wollten sie nicht dass beamte
die meist aus der mittelschicht haben
zusätzliche privilegien bekommen aber
frankreich ist eben nicht schwer
wir reden hier über eine sehr elitäres
land um die reine vorstellung zu geben
fast alle politischen führungskräfte in
frankreich von der gleichen universität
der école nationale d'administration an
dieser hochschule werden die kinder der
eliten zu politikern ausgebildet in der
letzten abschlussklasse kann nur ein
prozent der schüler aus einer familie
mit geringerem einkommen
mit anderen worten zu seltsam ist auch
klingen mag das land der freiheit
gleichheit und brüderlichkeit elita riss
muss in sein erbgut eingebrannt man
könnte sagen dass frankreich eine
permanente revolution von der
republikaner durch legt die tief in
ihrem inneren alle kaiser sein holen wir
sprechen also von einer mit privilegien
durchsetzen sozialstaat da gibt es zum
beispiel die berufs beamten mit
absoluter arbeitsplatzgarantie
heutzutage eigentlich ein totaler luxus
außerdem sollte ein beamter in
frankreich anders als in schweden
praktisch genauso gut bezahlten
arbeitnehmer in der privatwirtschaft
weil ich jedoch den wettbewerb und allen
normalen risiken dort ausgesetzt ist
aber wenn du denkst das sei schon
ungerecht dass man auch welche rollen
über einen französischen beamten erst
hereinbrechen sobald diese in den
ruhestand geht während in privaten
unternehmen das gehalt eine person in
den letzten 25 jahren zur berechnung der
rente herangezogen wird werden bei den
renten der beamten wir jetzt ein sechs
jahre ihres arbeitslebens berücksichtigt
und natürlich kannst du dir vorstellen
dass sie eben in diesen letzten jahren
riesige boni erhalten stell dir zum
beispiel jemanden vor der seine karriere
als junior beginnt und ist in seiner
firma schließlich bis zum partnerschaft
eine karriere wie sie nur wenige
hinbekommen da muss man sich schon ein
leben lang gehörig ins zeug legen
erfolgreich ist es jedoch gut möglich
dass dieser fleißige menschen in der
privatwirtschaft dann als rentner
schlechter gestellt ist als jeder noch
so laschet beamte und du fragst dich
vielleicht ob das problem in frankreich
ist nur daran liegt dass es einige
gruppen gibt die besseren bedingungen
haben aus der rest nun das problem ist
dass wenn irgendjemand versucht ihre
renten anzutasten
diese speziellen gruppen sofort auf die
barrikaden gehen andererseits wer würde
es ihnen verdenken stellt sich zum
beispiel vor die youtuber bekämen schon
seit jahrzehnten jeden monat 2000 euro
vom staat einfach so nur weil wir alle
so hübsche nasen haben da kann man sich
schon daran gewöhnen geld und plötzlich
würde irgendwo einen dahergekommen und
versuchen uns dieses privileg
wegzunehmen und christine vorstellen
dass ich wenn ich zwei mal die frage
stellen würde ob das fest oder nicht wir
würden den größten kanal schlugen mit
protest videos gegen diese böse böse
regierung die das ende der zivilisation
der menschheit herbei beschwört wir
würden euch unsere treuen fans alle dazu
aufrufen diese schurken mit fackeln und
mistgabeln aus dem land zu jagen und das
würde jedoch für uns tun oder
[Musik]
ja das mag sich jetzt vielleicht wie
eine ulkige übertragung anhören aber
genauso was spielt sich jedes mal wenn
ein politiker die rentenreform ihren
wollte auf den straßen flogen die fetzen
jacques chirac wollte als erster den
sonder regelungen an den kragen
scheiterte aber die gewerkschafts
proteste von 1995 sind mittlerweile
legendär später direkt moussa koussa und
ordnung und auf einige änderungen traut
sich aber nicht sich bei den
privilegierten gruppen einzumischen
trotzdem wollten beide regierungen ob
rechts oder sozialistisch durch die
mobilisierung der gewerkschaften unter
druck gesetzt allerdings ist das womit
diese präsidenten zu kämpfen hatten
nichts im vergleich zu heute schwerste
auseinandersetzungen paramilitärische
polizeieinsätze gegen demonstranten und
du fragst dich angesichts der heftigkeit
dieses konflikts was zu einer höhle
reformismus dieser neoliberalem acorda
verbrochen haben was genau hat er getan
um krassere proteste zu provozieren als
die von 1995 also aufgepasst
[Musik]
parasiten
mittlerweile fragst du dich vielleicht
was sind die wichtigsten änderungen die
makro vorschlägt nichts geringeres als
die abschaffung der 42 sonder
rentensystem das aktuelle rentensystem
läuft total aus dem ruder es tief in den
roten zahlen und einfach nicht mehr in
der lage sich irgendwelche privilegien
leisten zu können als alternative
schlägt makro ein universelles
punktesystem vorbei denn alle renten
beitragszahler punkte erhalten und es
keine rolle mehr spielen in welchem
sektor sie arbeiten diese punkte werden
für acer oder maschine beamte oder
youtuber genau gleich viel wert sein
aber jetzt hatte ich mal fest die
randale begannen schon bevor diese
reform überhaupt vorgestellt wurde
ja obwohl die gewerkschaften noch keinen
blassen schimmer hatten wie die reform
aussehen würde und ihre mitglieder auch
noch gar nicht wussten wie sie sich für
sie auswirken würde begann sich schon
mal vorsorglich gegen die regierung zu
protestieren
warum nun weil alle die im genuss von
privilegien sind genau wissen dass diese
langfristig untragbar sind eine
ungeheure belastung für die ganze
gesellschaft sie wussten dass ihre zeit
ausläuft
und es gibt noch eine andere sache die
wir beim akku seiner partei leidet blick
nicht ignorieren können und die ist dass
sowohl die linke als auch die rechte mit
micron bluten werden denn die situation
ist die folgende nach der regierung des
sozialisten hollande der erhebliche
kürzungen beschlossen hat suchte die
arbeiterklasse nach antworten bei
anderen politischen kräften
daher hat die mobilisierung gegen die
rentenreform eine gelegenheit die linke
geschaffen die straßen zurückzuerobern
trotz anderer bewegungen die sich ihrer
kontrolle entziehen wie die der geld
westen so ist diese debatte einerseits
zu einer sehr guten gelegenheit für die
gewerkschaften geworden welche für sich
in anspruch den die menschen gegen die
regierung zu verteidigen
aber auch für die extreme rechte
denn in der ära von chirac oder sarkozy
war alles sehr klar und dann beschwert
sich jetzt die linke und gewerkschaften
aber die französische politik ist heute
viel komplizierter als das sowohl die
extreme linke als auch die extreme
rechte laufen sturm gegen macau während
einmal mehr also außerhalb frankreichs
ein hervorragendes image genießt ist es
innerhalb band reißt das genaue
gegenteil für die linke ist ein böser
kapitalist der gegen arbeitnehmerrechte
ist für die rechnung ist ein grüner der
privilegien die tief in der nationalen
identität verwursten sind abschaffen
will und wo kanalisieren sich all diese
emotionen nun eben in diesen
massenprotesten
die aber hat makro diese reaktion der
straße erwidert nun sein erster schritt
war sehr konventionell zu einem
vertreter der neuen politik 6000 jahren
daumendrücken los und natürlich wenn man
den präsidenten der geld bestens unit
liegt die sache für die regierung etwas
aus dem ruder
marco prangert polizeigewalt an und
fordert einen verbesserten ethikkodex
die renten machen derzeit 17 prozent des
französischen bruttoinlandsprodukts aus
in der oecd liegt der durchschnitt bei
8% im wahlkampf bei den wahlen die
inklusiv palast brachten versprach er
dass er die rentenreform ihren würde
und obwohl sein einsatz ehrgeizig war
groß seine maßnahmen abgebildet die
reform wird nicht die über 45-jährigen
betreffen außerdem wird sich auch nicht
für lokführer über 35 jahre gelten und
sie wird nur tänzerinnen und tänzer an
der pariser oper betreffen die ab 2022
dort arbeiten aber das größte zugestellt
das birgt einen politischen coup marco
wurde das renteneintrittsalter mit
vollen bezügen auf 46 jahre anheben
das ziel war es die menschen zu
ermutigen später in den ruhestand zu
gehen und so das wichtigste das system
ist das 12 milliarden euro erreichen
könnte wenigstens ein wenig abzumildern
die regierung gab jedoch bekannt dass
sie die 64 jahre ist ganz aufgibt um den
ball an jemand anderen zu spielen dann
in reinform gewerkschaften und
arbeitgeber haben drei monate zeit wo
bis 2027 einen finanziellen ausgleich zu
finden doch all diese diskussionen mit
dem kronos zum stillstand
sowohl die arbeitgeber als auch die
gewerkschaften haben sich in der
regierung darauf geeinigt dieses thema
bis zum jahr 2021 ruhen zu lassen
tja und in diesem jahr befinden wir uns
ja jetzt und die politische situation
hat sich etwas verändert
interessanterweise sind makros
zustimmungswerte mit corona gewachsen
moment ist mit 40 prozent zustimmung der
beliebteste präsident frankreichs seit
20 jahren in der tat könnte er in diesem
jahrhundert der erste französische
präsident werden den die wiederwahl
gelingt aber so sicher darf er sich dann
auch nicht sein
zum zeitpunkt der erstellung dieses
videos gab es viele umfragen in denen
immer noch gleichauf mit marine le pen
liegt im moment hat seinen
gesetzesentwurf der us-senat erreicht
und wurde mit sage und schreibe 41 1000
änderungsanträge bedacht das macht aber
nichts
marco hat eine ausreichende mehrheit um
die rentenreform zu verabschieden wie er
es für richtig hält jetzt ist die frage
also und sich gerichtet du bist du dass
man seine rentenreform durchziehen kann
und inwieweit wird sie ist eine
wiederwahl beeinflussen wie sieht es mit
den rentensystemen dann land aus glaubst
du die rente ist sicher
teilt eure meinung bitte die immer mit
uns und auch an anderen im
kommentarbereich unter diesem video
ich hoffe dass euch dieses video
gefallen hat als ja geht uns bitte ein
leid heißt es mit euren freunden und
vergesst nicht unseren teil auch zu
abonnieren mach's gut und ist
[Musik]